Das war's für heute.
Ich wünsche euch einen schönen Abend.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Halter Unity Media Was ist denn hier los?
Was ist denn hier los?
Unity Media, was ist hier los?
Jetzt, jetzt?
Was war das, was war das Rumgelegge im Unity Media?
Alter, Unity Media!
Was, was war da los?
Hab's genau gesehen.
Hab's genau gesehen, Unity Media.
Es entgeht mir nichts, Unity Media, wenn ihr kack Performance habt.
Ich seh alles.
Monkeys.
Ich seh übrigens noch keinen Chat, ich muss erst mal einen 2. Rechner anmachen.
Aber...
Aber warum steht da eigentlich nicht 60 fps dahinter, haben wir 60 fps?
Eigentlich 60 fps, aber wo lässt man sich mal anzeichen, jetzt? Wir haben 60 fps, 64 fps,
big brain fps haben wir, sag ich euch leute, huge brain, poggers brain.
Weiß ich nicht so ganz, als kann ich den Kram mal zumachen. Weiß ich nicht so ganz,
du kannst nicht Updates installieren, wir konnten nicht Updates installieren, sagt Microsoft.
Egal, Hauptsache es funktioniert. Schon überstellt, ich bin da zwei Minuten dran. Ah ja, so jetzt
wunderbar. Muss ich erstmal vom letzten Streben den ganzen Kram jetzt machen, was haben wir
denn hier in der Ruf? Machen wir ein eigenes Fenster, sonst mach ich auch das Stick aus.
Lautstärke müsste passen. Votes gehen auch, schön. Ok, nice. So Unity Media, wird noch
geleckt oder hat sich das erledigt? Achso welchen Twitch Server nehmen wir? Ach ich nehme immer
noch Stockholm, sollte ich vielleicht mal umstellen. Das habe ich letztens umgestellt,
wo es so kaputt war. Warum stehen da eigentlich die 60 fps nicht? Vor allem stand da auch
immer 60. Dahinter. Oder verwechsel ich das jetzt? Derjenige mit dem Namen, den ich nicht
richtig aussprechen kann, ist drei Monate dabei. GWOZ30Gender, big brain name auf jeden
Fall. Ja aber, scheint alles zu funktionieren. Ok, sehr schön. 6,6% CPU Last, das ist natürlich
für nix. Kiyokone ist auch am Start. Drei Monate, oh es wird langsam Zeit für die goldene
Subscriber-Batch, die wir nicht am Start haben. Kümmer mich dieses Wochenende um Emotes und
Subscriber-Batches. Da nicht immer, ich weiß. Zystar, Twitch Prime, dankeschön. So, Unity
3. Oh, mein Vorschaurechner hängt. Vielleicht war es doch nicht gut, dass er keine Updates
inszeniert. Na ja. Guck mal, wenn man seinen eigenen Namen nicht mal schreiben kann. Ist
das Mikrofon abgekackt? Nope. Ist nicht. Ist ganz schön leise heute, ich glaube ich hab's
zu weit weg. So, ne. Ups, warum labert das Video mit mir? Was ist da los, es verwirrt
mich. So, wunderbar, alles, alles gut. Wie läuft zu dem Fiverr-Projekt? Ist doch schon
zwei, zwei, drei Wochen fertig. Musik bisschen leiser, ja das machen wir. 30, 30. Vielleicht
bisschen cooler, also. Es ist geil, dass der Slider irgendwie rum sich richtig slidet.
Ja so, so ist die Musik, denke ich, okay. Das ist eigentlich von der Lautstärke, gut.
Ich bin nicht so lange on, ne. Zwei Stunden oder so, mal gucken, zwei Stunden, weil ich
hab morgen den letzten Tag von meiner Microsoft Azure-Schulung und Leute, ich sag euch, es
ist so langweilig. Ich hab nix gelernt, was ich nicht hätte alleine innerhalb von 45
Minuten lernen können. Und es ist voll mit irgendwelchem Microsoft-Kack, wo kein Mensch
draufkommt. Irgendwelche komischen Assistenten, die du durchklicken musst, irgendwelche komischen
Tools, die du auf 30 verschiedenen Seiten zusammensuchen musst, warum auch immer es
da keinen Installer für Azure-Tools gibt oder sowas. Man muss irgendwie so ne ganz merkwürdige,
PowerShell verwenden wollen, muss man da irgendwie sich 20.000 Sachen nachinstallieren. Es ist
typisch Microsoft. Aber das Schöne ist, das Schöne ist, es gibt eine, ein gebasch, ein
Azure-Command-Line-Tool und das ist richtig nice. Das heißt, dass Azure, Microsoft Azure
scheint wirklich das erste Produkt von Microsoft zu sein, was sich unter Linux besser bedienen
lässt als unter Windows. Ich weiß nicht so wirklich, was mit Microsoft da los ist, aber
ich bin der Letzte, der damit irgendwelche Probleme hat. Wenn DB so scheiße ist, wieso
nicht Flickstrain nutzen? Naja, weil Flickstrain meine Strecke nicht fährt, das ist einfach.
Kannst du einen Vergleich zu AWS sehen? Nee, ich habe beides und nicht genug verwendet im
Vergleich zu AWS. AWS habe ich eigentlich gar nicht verwendet. Also ich sage mal so gut
wie gar nicht. Zu Google kann ich auch nichts sagen. Pornetis, das ist ja eher was zum
Selbsthosten, gibt es da auch Management-Plattformen. Aber Azure ist glaube ich, wenn man sich das
so anguckt, auf jeden Fall die letzten Jahre zu einem der wichtigsten Cloud-Anbieter aufgestiegen
und eine Sache habe ich schon gecheckt an dieser ganzen Microsoft Azure-Geschichte. Jeder
noch so kleinste Furz, den du lässt, kostet. Also es kostet in Azure wirklich gefühlt
alles, irgendwas. Kannst du in Azure gar nicht mal irgendwie auf die Idee kommen mal was
anzuklicken, das kostet gleich instant. Also das ist auf jeden Fall nicht ohne. Ansonsten
habe ich halt in diesem komischen Azure-Training von Microsoft, also wen das interessiert,
das ist das Azure-Training, das Operation Azure-Training oder so wie es heißt. Azure-Training
103 ist das. Der Microsoft Azure Administrator Training, Fastlane Training, das ist also
quasi für die Leute mit besonders großem Brain, die einfach nur ganz kurze Erklärungen
brauchen, alles instant checken. Also quasi wie gemacht für Next Level Big Brain Leute
wie mich. Ich glaube, dass der Kurs an sich gar nicht so schlecht ist. Aber unser Typ,
der das hält, man kann sich ja mal so ein Beispiel davon angucken. Die machen übrigens
ein Megasecret um ihre Schulungsunterlagen. Ich habe mir schon gedacht, eher, ob wir uns
nicht einfach mal ganz kurz die Schulungsunterlagen von Azure hier im Stream angucken. Aber die
sind richtig, die sind übelst hinterher. Die geben dir Schulungsunterlagen, aber das
ist so typische Microsoft-Stellgeschichte. Die geben dir Schulungsunterlagen für diesen
Kurs, die kannst du allerdings nur online angucken, nur seitenweise und wenn du Speichers
kommst, kommt nur Mist bei raus. Also die haben da wirklich DRM Schulungsunterlagen
und es ist echt mega für den Arsch. Zumindest das größte Problem an diesem Kurs, muss ich
jetzt einfach mal so sagen, ist der Typ, der den Kurs macht bei uns. Ich sage jetzt nicht,
wer es ist, ich will ihn jetzt nicht flamen. Ich würde eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass
er schon ordentlich Übung haben müsste in diesem Kurs, aber irgendwie, es wirkt auf
mich übelst unstrukturiert und auch mega langweilig gemacht. Eigentlich hat dieses Fastlane Training
für Azure ziemlich viele Übungen drin und wir machen keine Übung. Der Typ kriegt die
ganze Zeit nur Powerpoint-Präsentationen durch. Heute haben wir mal eine Übung gemacht
und die Übung bestand Microsoft typisch aus, klicke hier drauf, dann geht so ein Azure
Lab auf, wo du ausprobieren kannst und dann, nicht etwa, dass da in der Übung drin steht,
so nach dem Motto, erstellen sie drei VMs und einen Loadbalancer und probieren sie aus,
dass alles funktioniert. Nein, die Übung oder sagen wir mal der Test, der sieht folgendermaßen
aus. Du klickst auf den öffnen Knopf und dann hast du neben einer Anleitung, wo drinnen
steht ganz genau, was du machen musst. Also es ist nicht, dass du was lernst. In dem Training,
also in diesem Training Lab, wo man übt, steht dann so nach dem Motto drinnen, klicken sie
jetzt auf alle Ressourcen, klicken sie auf Computing, klicken sie auf virtuelle Maschine
anlegen, klicken sie auf Microsoft Data Center, Windows Data Center 2016 Edition, klicken
sie auf weiter, klicken sie auf Network, klicken sie jetzt hier auf Public IP erstellen, klicken
sie Public IP ein, klicken sie jetzt hier auf weiter. Das ist doch keine Übung. Was
soll das denn sein? Ja und geben sie ihre Kreditkarteninfos ein, aber wir haben zum
Glück 100 Dollar Credit, wo wir rumsaunen können und ich habe heute ganze, passt mal
auf, wie viel Geld ich heute in meiner Azure-Schulung ausgegeben habe, ganze 2,10 Euro. Also ohne
Scheiß, was ich bisher in dieser Azure-Schulung gelernt habe, hätte ich in 45 Minuten alleine
rausgekriegt. Es ist ja auch vor allem nicht kompliziert gemacht. Die haben das, ich muss
sagen, man, du kannst wirklich in Azure, also in dieser Microsoft Cloud, kannst du wirklich
all den möglichen Scheiß einstellen. Alles und alles kostet auch irgendwie extra. Aber
sie haben es geschafft, dass es irgendwie noch ansatzweise selbst erklärend ist, wie
du was machst. Du musst dir so ein paar Basics merken, dass du nicht VMs anlegst, sondern
erst mal Netzwerkkarten anlegst, IPs anlegst und dann VMs anlegst und das verbindest und
sowas, ist alles okay. Aber wenn man das mal gecheckt hat, geht das auch. Aber langweilig,
da kann man echt so einen Kurs nicht aufbauen. So war die SAP-Schulung bei uns an der Uni.
Viele Schulungen sind leider so langweilig. Ich dachte der Tiefpunkt war diese eine Cisco-Schulung,
die ich mal vor Jahren gemacht habe. Die war nämlich ähnlich, aber die war im Endeffekt
noch interessanter, weil du ab und zu mal ein paar Kabel in den Switch stöpseln durftest.
Aber ansonsten war das wirklich übelst langweilig. Wie kann man sich so eine Schulung als unwissender
vorstellen? Ähnlich wie Schule. Diese Schulung ist schlimmer als Schule. In der Schule hast
du noch... Also, so wie der das macht. Ich gehe nämlich mal davon aus, wenn es jemand
macht, der das gut kann, dann ist das auch deutlich interessanter, weil Azure ist eigentlich
ein interessantes Thema. Also, die normale Schulung ist eigentlich ein bisschen wie Schule.
Du hast irgendeinen Typ, der kennt sich halt damit aus, der steht dann vorne, erklärt
dir ein bisschen was und je nachdem, was das für ein Typ von Schulung ist, ist es halt
mehr so mehr mit Practice oder halt mehr mit Theorie und Geschwätze. Ich denke immer ein
bisschen davon ab, wie der das macht und was man auch für eine Schulung gebucht hat.
Aber man kann sich das schon ein bisschen wie Schulung vorstellen. Allerdings, bei dem
ist das schlimmer als Schule, weil Schule ist noch ein bisschen interaktiv. Da fragt
der Lehrer ab und zu mal was und wenn es dich interessiert, kannst du was sagen oder kannst
sagen, ist mir wurscht. Aber das geht ja... Du kannst da schon was fragen, aber es gibt
nichts zu fragen, weil das einfach nur PowerPoint-Präsentationen durchgeklickt ist bei dem. Das ist wirklich
übelst langweilig. Außerdem spricht da die meisten englischen Wörter noch merkwürdiger
aus als ich. Der sagt zum Beispiel Storage Tier, so wie das deutsche Tier, also so wie
man Tier ausspricht, so Animal auf Englisch, so Storage Tier, also die Stufe vom Storage,
also sprich, das ist eine SSD, also wie schnell ist der Zugriff da drauf. Storage Tier spricht
da die ganze Zeit Storage Tire aus. Da kriege ich übelste Anfälle, ich denke die ganze
Zeit an irgendein Rad, was da durch mein Rechenzentrum fährt, wenn da einer mit Storage Tire ankommt.
Das heißt Storage Tier, das ist wie wenn du Tier 1 Epic-Rüstung hast oder sowas. Ach
ja, und Q, also das da, Warteschlange, ich weiß gar nicht wie das auf Deutsch, ob man
das auf Deutsch Warteschlange nennt. Wie heißt denn das eigentlich auf Deutsch? Warteschlange,
tatsächlich, weiter Warteschlange heißt es. Siehst du hier, da steht sogar die Ausprache,
Q spricht man das aus. Q. Und der Kell sagt dazu, QI. Da denke ich immer an den Händen,
Heli aus Modern Warfare 2. Erst mal Payflow am Start. Aber es wird alles noch getoppt,
es wird echt alles noch getoppt. Gateway, ich weiß gar nicht ob man dazu überhaupt
ne Ausprache dahinter hat. Gateway, dachte die ganze Zeit Gutway dazu. Das triggert mich
jedes Mal wenn er sagt Gutway. Wir müssen ein Gutway Netz anlegen. Gutway, Gutway, Gutway
sagt er, Gutway Netz. Das triggert mich immer übelst, da muss ich mich immer zusammenreißen.
Frag ihn mal wie er GIF oder JIF ausspricht, das wüsste ich echt mal. Also ich kann diesen
Kurs echt nicht empfehlen, falls den irgendjemand auf der Arbeit vorgeschlagen kriegt oder gefragt
ob er den machen möchte, kann ich echt nicht empfehlen. Es könnte sein, dass dieser Azure
Fast Training Kurs ganz gut ist, aber es scheint mir viel zu sehr abhängig davon wer den macht
und das bei uns ist einfach stink gelangweilt, jemand der hat nix. Wie viel seid ihr in der
Schulung, ist das so ein 100 Leute Online-Ding? Nein, nein, nein, nein. Die haben da richtig
Geld für bezahlt. Das ist Offline-Training bei uns in der Firma von einem Typ, der es
eigentlich kann. Wir sind 6 Leute, also eigentlich was wo man was lernen könnte, aber macht man
ja nichts. Ja und es ist auch noch bei uns in der Firma Azure, noch halb 1.000, 3 Monate.
Also ich muss ja gleich Face Rollen. Danke für die ganzen Stubs. Muss jetzt mal schnell
gucken, da ich nix übersehen hab. Streamlabs. Das ist der Wahnsinn, da hab ich mir erstmal
genug drüber ausgekotzt, aber. Es war wirklich ätzend. Läufts jetzt eigentlich ordentlich
hier das Stream oder lagts rum, weil am Anfang hat es ja ein bisschen bugged. EVE1337, Twitch
Prime Sub, Poggers. Nice. Eukon hatten wir schon, ne? Aber trotzdem noch ein Dank für
den Sub. Silent Pain resubbed. 3 Monate. Gehen die Subs aber ab. Ich muss mal kurz gucken,
wie viele Subs ich überhaupt hab jetzt. Ja, nämlich schon wieder ein neues Subgoal erreicht.
So langsam, aber sicher muss ich echt mal beikommen mit meinen Emotes. Wie viel haben
wir denn jetzt? 366. Heide Global Elite, Twitch Prime. Jetzt gehts aber echt ab. Warum steht
Any% in den Streamtags? Da ist ja irgendwo Any%. Wir fangen immer Sachen an und machen
sie nie fertig. Also quasi mehr oder weniger die Definition von Any%. Also und machen sie
nie komplett fertig. So rum. Bei Any% gehts ja, dass du es irgendwie fertig machst. Das
machen wir ja meistens. Hawks, Twitch Prime. 2 Monate. Ja, aber jetzt hab ich mich genug
über diese komische Asher-Sache ausgekotzt. Ich mein, im Endeffekt ist es morgen wieder
vorbei, ne? Das letzte Tag. Mal gucken, was wir am letzten Tag machen. Vielleicht machen
wir noch ein paar Übungen, aber es ist... Was hältst du von Cold Wars? Weiß jetzt,
sagt mir jetzt gar nix. Ist das diese Geschichte, wo du... Ist das quasi das, wo es auch diese
Wer schreibt schneller Geschichte? Ich muss euch übrigens auch fragen, Leute, was ich
für ein nächstes Video machen soll. Ich bin mir noch nicht so ganz sicher. Und zwar,
ich hab zur Auswahl. Einmal wollte ich ja noch ein Fazit machen zur Modern Warfare Beta.
Alternativ hab ich mir gedacht, ich verbinde das mal ein bisschen damit. Ich hab zwei Sachen
oder drei Sachen zur Auswahl. Entweder dann Modern Warfare Beta-Fazit-Video oder aber
in Kombination mit, dass ich mich drüber aufrege, dass wahrscheinlich ein nicht unerheblicher
Teil von Modern Warfare 4, zumindest Gerüchte nach, ich glaub offiziell bestätigt ist das
immer noch nicht, muss ich mal nachgucken, PS4 exklusiv sein wird. Dieser komische Spec
of Survival Mode, gehen da die Gerüchte um, dass der... Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das mittlerweile
bestätigt ist, vielleicht weiß das einer von euch, dass das PS4 exklusiv sein soll.
Das ist eine Sache, die kann ich nicht unterstützen. Und ich bin eh kein Freund von Exklusivität.
Also gegen ein bisschen exklusive Inhalte hab ich nix. Aber wenn ein kompletter Spielmodus
exklusiv ist auf einer anderen Plattform und nicht etwa irgendwie für 1-2 Wochen, sondern
für ein ganzes Jahr, ist das absoluter Rotz. Gude bin nur kurz zum Subben da, huge Sub.
Kommt kein Battle Royale, weiß ich nicht. So und das nächste was ich... Also das ist
eine Videosache, die man machen könnte. Das zweite ist eine Sache, wo ich mich auch echt
drüber aufgeregt hab gestern. Ich hab auf Reddit auf... Ihr wisst ja, ich hab sau viel
Overwatch gespielt zur Release. Und das meist gelesene Subreddit, was ich damals gelesen hab,
war Competitive Overwatch. Das war noch die Zeiten, wo wir Skrims gesucht haben mit dem
Steam und übelst übelst reingesuchtet haben. Auch relativ gut waren für die damalige Zeit.
So und ich hab jetzt hier ganz viele im Competitive Overwatch Subreddit. Ja, neues Reddit Design,
geh mal fort. Ja, so ist das doch schon. Wie kommt man eigentlich auf die Idee, so was
schönes hier mit einer ordentlichen Navigation und so, so was Merkwürdiges umzubauen. Wenn
das was ich gelesen hab, es hat nur begrenzt was mit Overwatch zu tun. Also es hat schon
viel mit Overwatch zu tun, aber das Problem ist nicht Overwatch. Und zwar, ich weiß nicht,
wer interessiert sich für euch für den Overwatch World Cup. Und hat da schon ein bisschen rumgeguckt.
Jetzt an den ein oder anderen. Ich mein, ich guck wenig, in letzter Zeit wenig Competitive
Overwatch. Ich guck ab und zu mal Overwatch League, wenns läuft. Aber ich muss sagen,
die World Cup Games hab ich jetzt nie großartig verfolgt. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein Aushängeschild
von Overwatch World, der World Cup. Also es ist in der Regel, ich würd sagen, von der
Aufmerksamkeit her, ist der World Cup nach der Overwatch League auf jeden Fall das, was
am meisten Aufmerksamkeit bekommt. Sagen wir mal so, das Niveau mag in der OWL natürlich
höher sein und das Niveau ist auch zum größten Teil in Contenders höher. Aber der World Cup
ist einfach das, wo viele Leute gucken. So und wisst ihr was Blizzard jetzt macht? Wo
ich nicht verstehe, warum sich irgendwie keiner drüber beschwert. Die haben ihre Regeln geändert.
Ich zeig euch das mal. Die haben ihre Regeln geändert für den Overwatch World Cup und
zwar. Ja. Ja. Das haben die vor 5 Monaten schon geschrieben. So und zwar steht da so
Sachen drin, wie das zum Beispiel nur die Top 10. Wo stehts denn? Da denkt man sich
erstmal noch gar nichts dabei, wenn man das so sieht. So also der erste Witz, ich schau
mal das Format. Die machen das jetzt so, dass es quasi keine nationalen Ausscheidungsdinger
Qualifier mehr gibt, sondern, dass es quasi auf der BlizzCon, bevor die BlizzCon offiziell
losgeht, gibt es quasi Vorrunde, wenn man es so will. Das Problem an der Vorrunde ist,
kann ich gleich mal sagen, es ist Open Single Elimination Bracket. Single Elimination Bracket
ist so ziemlich das beknackteste Turnierformat, was es gibt. Single Elimination bedeutet,
du verlierst ein Spiel und bist raus. Double Elimination ist viel schöner. Double Elimination
ist eigentlich das, was man von den meisten Turnieren kennt, wenn die das nicht in der
Liga machen oder in der Gruppenphase machen. Double Elimination ist diese Geschichte mit,
man verliert, kommt ins Lower Bracket, man verliert nochmal und man ist raus. Oder aber,
man verliert einmal und gewinnt danach alle Spiele, dann kommt man auch weiter. Single
Elimination ist schonmal übelst fail, aber das ist ja nur, das ist noch gar nicht so
wild. Der Witz kommt jetzt ja gleich, ich muss mal gucken, wo sie das hier hingeschrieben
hat. How to get involved, blablabla, blablabla. Wo steht das denn mit dem Hotel, haben sie
das jetzt raus? Ach hier, National Rankings. Also die 10 Teams, die besten 10 Teams vom
letzten Jahr, hier, this year before match start, blablabla. Also das ganze wird gesiedelt
je nachdem, wie das ist. Hier, competition, 10 highest ranked Teams, das sind also die,
die im Prinzip im letzten Jahr gewonnen haben, die bekommen vollen Support. Das heißt, die
bekommen ihren Trip, also die bekommen die Reisekosten erstattet, die bekommen Anreise
erstattet, die kriegen das Hotel bezahlt und alles ist gut. So und jetzt kommt der
Hit, jetzt kommt der absolute Knaller, Leute, der absolute Knaller. Alle anderen Länder,
die teilnehmen wollen, sind komplett selbst dafür verantwortlich, ihre Reisekosten und
Unterhalt und alles zu bezahlen. Da frage ich mich nur, Alter, was geht mit Blizzard
eigentlich ab? Ich meine, wie soll ein Team, wie soll ein Team, ach ja, okay, ich muss
ja das mal in der Reihe nachmachen. Wie soll ein Team, das sagen wir mal aus, ups, äh,
warte, fuck, was, ich hab mich gemuted, ey, warte mal kurz, äh, fuck, Alter, okay, ach,
jetzt funkt sie jetzt. Okay, ähm, wie soll ein Team aus, sagen wir mal, was weiß ich,
gibt's denn da, Trinidad and Tobago oder so, falls dieses Land so heißt oder, sagen wir
mal, nehmen wir einfach Team Südafrika, ja, Südafrika ist jetzt nicht so ein ganz dritter
Weltland, aber Südafrika hat jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel Kohle. Ähm, wie sollen
ein Team, wie Südafrika, wie sollen die sich das leisten? Wie sollen die sich das
leisten? So, und wisst ihr, wisst ihr was die ganzen Teams jetzt machen, übrigens
Team Germany auch, Team Germany auch, ähm, die machen jetzt alle Crowdfounding, die machen
jetzt alle GoFoundMe und machen, machen quasi, ähm, äh, Streams, wo die Leute spenden
können und sowas, und das ist, wenn man sich das mal auf der Zunge, auf, auf der, wie gesagt
in CS kriegt kein Team was bezahlt, das ist was komplett anderes, das hier sind No-Name-Teams,
das sind No-Name-Teams ohne Sponsor, die noch nicht mal einen Sponsor, selbst wenn die Teams,
selbst wenn die Teams einen Sponsor hätten, die dürfen es nicht auf das Trikot machen.
Das sind, das sind kein, das sind No-Name-Teams, das sind zum größten, zum großen Teil No-Name-Player,
da ist keine Orga und nichts dahinter und, und selbst eine Orga würde sich das zweimal
überlegen da was zu supporten, weil die Spieler noch nicht mal den Kram auf ein fucking Trikot
tragen dürfen.
Die meisten Spieler, die, die im World Cup mitmachen aus den 50 Ländern sind im Vergleich
zur Overwatch League No-Names, da sponsert keiner einfach mal nebenbei 15k, da gehts
aber auch überhaupt nicht drum, es geht ja drum, dass, das, jetzt muss ich wieder zurück
kommen, dass ich das eigentlich eine Sauerei von Blizzard finde, es ist die offizielle
Messe von Blizzard, es ist das offizielle Overwatch World Cup Turnier, es ist quasi
der offizielle Stream, die gehen dahin, die spielen für Blizzard ein Spiel von Blizzard
auf dem offiziellen Stream, das dem Spiel Hype gibt und, und sonst was und dass Blizzard
überhaupt diese Veranstaltung machen kann, ist nur diesen Spielern zu verdanken und Blizzard
sagt einfach Nö, da bezahlen wir nix für und der Hit ist, es gibt Overwatch World Cup
Leakos, das passt mal auf, die sehen übrigens übelst wie Arsch aus.
Es hat irgendwie einer eine coole Seite gemacht mit der Übersicht, es hat irgendwie einer
coole Übersichtsseite gemacht, Overview, ja, die meine ich nicht, übrigens erstens
sehen die Dinger voll für'n Arsch aus, die Overwatch World Cup Hose, also das sind die
uninspiriertesten World Cup T-Shirts, die ich je gesehen hab und der Witz ist, es gibt
offizielle World Cup T-Shirts und was meint ihr, wie viel die Teams von den Verkäufen
der Overwatch T-Shirts, der World Cup T-Shirts abbekommen?
Laut meinen letzten Informationen, die ich gelesen hab, nix, nix, das ist Skamars, ohne
Ende alter, was ist mit, was ist mit Blizzard los, was ist mit Blizzard los, das kann man
nicht mit einem CSGO-Tunnel vergleichen, ich würd mir ja irgendwie wünschen, dass alle
Teams sagen, Blizzard leck mich und wir fahren einfach nicht hin, da sollen sie einfach
Korea den Autowind geben, sollen einfach Korea den Autowind geben und sagen, Gutes,
und es ist ja nicht mal so, als würde das, es ist ja noch nicht mal so, als würde das
Blizzard wahnsinnig viel Geld kosten, guck mal, 50.000 Euro für'n Team, für 50 Teams,
das sind 750.000 Euro, was zum Teufel interessiert Blizzard 750.000 Euro, ich hab auf Reddit
Leute gesehen, die diese Scheiße verteidigen, die sagen dann, ja, aber Blizzard muss auch
gucken, dass sie irgendwie mit Geld verdienen, die verdienen genug Geld, die sollen sich
den letzten Financial Report mal angucken, die verdienen Milliarden, da als wäre 750.000
Euro, das ist für Blizzard ungefähr, das ist für Blizzard, ist das weniger, als ihr
dem Dönermann als Trinkgeld gebt, und selbst wenn du als Team gut spielst und in die Preisgeldringe
kommst, da hast du grad mal deine Ausgaben rein, dass die Leute, ich versteh gar nicht,
warum da überhaupt niemand freiwillig hinfährt, ich weiß nicht, ich glaub das Preisgeld ist
noch nicht, ist noch nicht announced, ja Small Indie Company, 750.000 Euro, das ist nix,
750.000 Euro, das ist das, was, wie heißt der Typ nochmal, Bobby Kotick oder so, wie
man damit ausspricht, was dem Activision Chef aus Versehen aus der Tasche fällt, wenn er
in der Kantine was bezahlen will, 750.000 Euro, das ist nix, und außerdem, ja Freddy
hat Recht, natürlich, das ist pures Marketing, es ist ja nicht so, dass die am World Cup viel
verdienen würden, aber gerade deswegen, weil es pures Marketing ist, warum bezahlt man
eigentlich für die Leute, die quasi die Aushängeschilder dieses Marketing sind, nämlich Spieler,
warum gibt man den, man, es ist ja nicht so, dass die umsonst spielen würden, also wenn
man, also normalerweise müsste man sagen, ok, man kriegt die Anreise bezahlt, man kriegt
den Aufenthalt bezahlt, man kriegt Verpflegung bezahlt und man kriegt noch eine Aufwandspauschale
fürs Spielen, so müsstest du das eigentlich machen, aber Blizzard, es sagt ja nicht nur,
du kriegst kein Geld fürs Spielen, quasi, die Spieler, die dafür sorgen, dass die überhaupt
dieses Marketing-trechtige Turnier abhalten können, kriegen kein Geld, nein, die Scheiße
noch mal doppelt drauf und sagen, nicht nur ihr kriegt kein Geld, keine Aufwandsentschädigung
und sonst was, nein, ihr müsst die komplette Scheiße auch noch selbst bezahlen und jetzt
kommt der Super, jetzt kommt noch der absolute Topper, jetzt toppen wir das Ganze noch mal
wenn ihr jetzt schon denkt, Blizzard hat sie eh schon wieder mal, dann muss ich euch
mal diesen Clip zeigen, von einem Spieler aus dem offiziellen Overwatch-Team, das müsst
ihr euch jetzt mal ganz genau anhören, was der sagt und dann zweifelt ihr wirklich daran,
was mit Blizzard los ist, das hat mir doch jemand auf Reddit, das hat mir doch jemand
auf hier, hört euch das mal an, das ist aus dem Stream von Raiddy, das ist ein Spieler,
glaubt May, May-Spieler aus dem deutschen Overwatch-Team, jetzt hört euch das mal genau
an was der sagt, ich weiß jetzt nicht welcher Clip das ist, deswegen gucken wir uns mal
beides an, wollen die mich verarschen?
Die kriegen nix mal was zu fressen, der Shit ist Single Elimination, jetzt kommen wir wieder
zum ursprünglichen Punkt zurück, Single Elimination, das bedeutet im schlimmsten Fall, überlegt
euch das mal, überlegt euch mal, ihr seid ein Spieler aus dem Land, wo 15.000 Euro verdammt
viel Geld sind, ihr kratzt das irgendwie zusammen, ihr macht Crowdfounding, ihr macht alles was
geht, ihr sponsort das im Prinzip noch, ihr sponsort quasi Blizzard, weil die kein Geld
haben das auszurichten anscheinend, ihr Crowdfounded das, wenn sowas ge Crowdfounded wird, das
bedeutet, dass im Prinzip die größten Fans dieses Spiels, das sind diejenigen, die Crowdfounden,
das ist übelst grotesk, diejenigen, die einen Overwatch-Team Crowdfounden, das sind mit
die größten Fans von Overwatch, sonst würden sie das nicht Crowdfounden, sprich, das sind
die Leute, die eh schon mehr als genug Geld Blizzard gegeben haben, was meine ich, Main
Sound?
Main Sound ist doch, meinst du mal Mikro, nee du meinst Desktop, ne, zumindest das sind
die Leute, die eh schon sau viel Geld an Blizzard gegeben haben, die sollen quasi Blizzard
jetzt noch sponsort das auszurichten können, das ist übelst grotesk, so und jetzt überlegt
euch mal, ihr seid in einem Team aus einem Land, wo 15.000 Euro übelst viel Geld sind,
ihr kratzt das zusammen, Crowdfounding von den Leuten, die eh schon genug Geld an Blizzard
bezahlt haben, ihr nehmt euer Erspartes vielleicht noch, ihr fahrt auf die BlizzCon, ihr habt
vielleicht noch irgendwelche Einreise-sonst-was-Probleme, ja, also ihr seid wahrscheinlich eh schon,
ihr müsst euch um den ganzen Scheiß kümmern, das ist die Zeit, wo ihr nicht trainieren
könnt, nicht üben könnt, nicht scrimmen könnt, nicht sonst was machen, ich weiß dafür
gibt es eigentlich den Team-Typ, aber da müssen sich alle drum kümmern, so und dann kommt
ihr da an und vielleicht habt ihr Pech, ja, und landet im ersten Match gegen einen Gegner,
der euch entweder haushoch überlegen ist oder ihr verliert das erste Match unglücklich,
so, Single Elimination, ihr seid direkt raus, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt noch nichtmal in welchem
Format das hier gespielt wird, ist es best of 3, wahrscheinlich ist es BO3, wahrscheinlich
ist es BO3, denke ich mal, BO1 wäre, na gut, ich traue Blizzard alles zu, eh, gehen wir
davon aus, dass es BO3 oder BO5, wahrscheinlich BO3, so, ihr geht dann dahin, ihr habt quasi
euer, sogar noch euer Erspartes dafür ausgegeben, ihr verliert unglücklich, ihr seid direkt
raus und dann sagt Blizzard nach dem Essen, bäh, jetzt kriegst du auch nicht mehr was
zu fressen, das ist sowas von dem, also das, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll,
ich weiß wirklich, ich weiß echt nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll, und was ich nicht verstehe
ist, warum das, das sind 8 Leute, ja, hast recht, ich verstehe gar nicht, warum erstens
das Leute auf Reddit überhaupt verteidigen und warum keiner sich irgendwie über diese
Sache aufregt, da mache ich auch ein Video drüber, ich warte jetzt noch, ich habe an
Blizzard was geschrieben, ich wollte mal denen ihre Meinung, ich werde natürlich nicht
darauf antworten, dann kannst du dir voll ausgehen, dass Blizzard nicht darauf antworten wird,
ich wollte noch warten, bis der deutsche Teammanagerin antworten kann, noch was, falls er noch was
antworten will, und dann mache ich dir mal ein Video zu, weil wenn das wirklich alles
so ist, vielleicht habe ich auch irgendeinen Punkt, Leute verteidigen das, ja, die sagen,
ach ja, Blizzard verdient mit dem Overwatch World Cup ja kein Geld, da müssen die ja gucken,
dass das irgendwie plus minus null geht, ich glaube, Noserino ist der Community Manager
und, und, Luki ist, nee, umgedreht, ach keine Ahnung, im Prinzip geht ja auch um Blizzard,
also ich gönne das den Leuten aus Deutschland wirklich, dass die da hinfahren, ich wollte
schon kurz, kurz sagen, als ich gesehen habe, dass die auch Probleme haben, die Kohle zusammen
zu kriegen, ich wollte schon ganz kurz auf Twitter schreiben, Leute, ich bezahle euch
den Kram, aber erstens, es ist ein Game, was mich persönlich nicht mal so großartig interessiert,
und zweitens will ich Blizzard keine 7000 Euro geben, das will ich einfach nicht, das sehe
ich nicht ein, da irgendwie was, was zu bezahlen, das ist doch gefälliges Blizzard machen,
das ist denen ihr scheiß Turnier, ja, und als wären 750.000 Euro für Blizzard wirklich
viel Geld, ich wünsche wirklich den Leuten, die da, die Teams, also ich wünsche Blizzard
erstmal einen scheiß World Cup für diese Aktion, aber ich wünsche den Teams selber,
dass die es hinkriegen mit ihrem Crowdfunding, dass die ein super Event haben, ja, dass die
schöne Erinnerungen haben, ich meine, das ist ja auch, das ist so eine Sache, das machst
du einmal im Leben, wenn du jetzt, wenn du nicht gerade wirklich Pro wirst, höchstens
zweimal, ja, ich glaube, die höchste Teilnahme irgendwie wird wahrscheinlich zweimal sein,
außer bei manchen Pros beim World Cup, das machst du einmal im Leben da hinfahren und
an diesem Event als Spieler teilnehmen, deswegen, ich gönne das den Leuten wirklich, ich freue
mich für die Leute, wenn das klappt, die sind teilweise auch noch relativ jung, da
hast du Leute dabei, die sind in Kram 18, da sind 18, 19, für die ist das natürlich
super, deswegen, für die hoffe ich wirklich, dass das klappt, aber so wie das Blizzard
hier macht, das kann ich nicht gut heißen, und ich meine, die werden doch garantiert,
garantiert bringen die wieder irgendwelche World Cup Skins raus, hundertprozentig, genau
Freddy, die bringen hundertprozentig irgendwelche World Cup Skins wieder raus, mit dem ganzen
Krempel, mit den Trikots, mit den World Cup Skins, da wäre wahrscheinlich schonmal ein
Großteil der Kosten für die Verpflegung und Anreise der Teams wieder drinnen, und selbst
wenn nicht, wir haben uns letztens mal den letzten Financial Report angeguckt, 750k,
natürlich kostet das gesamte Event und die Organisation dieses Cups natürlich bedeutend
mehr, wie das was man bezahlen muss für die Spieler, keine Frage, aber es kann doch nicht
sein, dass die Spieler die Leidtragenden sind, eigentlich sollten, wenn wirklich, als Spieler
solltest du eigentlich bei so einem Event, ich nenne es mal so ein bisschen in Watte
gepackt sein, dass du dich auf nichts anderes konzentrieren musst, außer gut zu spielen.
Du solltest dir als Spieler nicht Gedanken machen müssen, ob du abends noch was essen
kannst.
Naja, ist Blizzard eine AG, aber sowas von, die Activision Blizzard Aktie, der AG zu
übrigens wieder besser, ich hoffe ihr freut euch alle, ja, war das Umsatz oder Gewinn?
Naja, das erste Mal ist Umsatz ja generell aller Einnahmen, minus das was du ausgegeben
hast, ist, wenn du Glück hast, Gewinn, ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, was genau im Financial
Report drinnen stand, aber die bringen jedes Quartal einen Financial Report raus, da kannst
du dir angucken, wenn du es genau wissen willst, und selbst wenn man als Außenseiter Team weiterkommt,
du musst, ich habe keine Ahnung, wann es wie viel Preisgeld gibt, du musst schon ganz
schön weit kommen, dass du überhaupt deine Aufwände reinbekommst, und das kann nicht
sein, das kann echt nicht sein, ich bin mal gespannt was diese BlizzCon noch dran kommt,
ob wir was neues hören zu Diablo Mobile, was gibt es da eigentlich, was schönes, was
neues, da hat man jetzt in Jahr lang nichts gehört, ja neue WoW Expansion ist wahrscheinlich
so sicher, oh, kein Release dieses Jahr, da bin ich ganz furchtbar traurig, ich mache
mir jetzt noch mal ein bisschen Gedanken drüber, wie ich das genau verpacke, weil ich will
jetzt kein Video machen, wo ich das hier so wie im Stream erzähle, das war jetzt ein
bisschen durcheinander, und Leute, wir wetten jetzt mal, wir wetten jetzt mal, im Stream
hier Leute, ja, es ist hier, Exposed, also, ich wette mit euch, wenn ich, also um was,
um was wetten wir, keine Ahnung, um, ja gut, ich kann mit euch nicht wetten, weil, wenn
ich gewinne, kriege ich nichts, und ja, um 20 Subs Leute, um 20 Subs wetten wir, aber
was ist, wenn ich gewinne, da habe ich nichts davon, da habe ich nichts von, außer, dass
ich mich geil fühlen kann, egal, genau, ich wette mit euch Leute, wenn ich das Video mache,
aber die wette kann ich eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht verlieren, wenn ich das Video
mache über Blizzard, und dass ich das nicht gut finde, wie sie das mit dem World Cup handhaben,
und den Support für die Spieler, wie heißt das Lied, 2 Stunden 22, beautiful study work
instrumental music mix, genau, also ich wette mit euch, wenn ich dieses Video mache über
den World Cup, da ich das nicht gut finde, wie Blizzard da auch mit den Spielern umgeht
und wie das organisiert ist, es kommt mindestens ein Blizzard Fanboy an, der sagt, Magst du
scheiß Blizzard Hater, oder, Magst du hast doch davon überhaupt keine Ahnung, Blizzard
macht das gut, oder, ja, mein Liebling, absolute Lieblings Aussage, Magst, Blizzard ist ein
gewinnorientiertes Unternehmen, und das Ziel eines gewinnorientierten Unternehmen ist es
möglichst viel Gewinn zu machen, das ist meine Lieblings Aussage bei sowas immer, das
ist die absolute Big Brain Aussage, da könnte ich mich immer aufrengen, als würde, ich weiß
nicht, was die Leute davon haben, sowas zu Fanboyen, das mag sein, dass Blizzard Ziel
ist, den möglichst größten Gewinn zu machen, aber, die 750.000 Euro fallen doch überhaupt
nicht auf in der Gesamtkalkulation von Blizzard, 750.000 Euro, wie gesagt, das verliert Bobby
Kotrig in der Kantine, es fällt ihm aus dem Säckel 750k, und mal ganz davon abgesehen,
wir sind nicht Blizzard, wenn Blizzard das so macht, können wir das trotzdem scheiße
finden, und das ist auch irgendwo das einzige, was wir machen können, und irgendwie mit unsere
Aufgabe als Community von so einem Game Blizzard auch zu sagen, dass wir das scheiße finden,
einfach irgendwie Blizzard da in den Arsch zu kriechen, was erhoffen sich die Leute eigentlich
davon, denken die wirklich, die schreiben in das Video rein, so nach dem Motto, oh Magst,
Blizzard, Beste, du Scheiße, dass dann irgendwann mal einer von Blizzard reingucken sagt, ah,
der xx360 Rust last nice noscoper auf YouTube hat den Magst geflamed, dass er uns schlecht
findet, das ist aber ein geiler Typ, da kriegt er 3 Skins gratis, nein, der Typ will niemals
in seinem Leben was von haben, Blizzard gefanboy zu haben, nie, die lachen sich höchstens
über den kaputt, unser wichser Typ, wenigstens einer kauft unsere Skins, TH, stream, Twitch
Prime, Dankeschön, Pop, so, jetzt habe ich mich genug über Blizzard und World Cup aufgeregt,
aber eigentlich müssen wir das gar nicht wetten, Leute, oder, das ist doch so klar,
wie, keine Ahnung, ich wollte jetzt nicht den Standard Close Prover gleich bringen,
es ist aber klar, dass das auf jeden Fall kommen wird, es ist doch so klar, klar wie
Gunner Optik Gaming Classes, weil die sind nicht klar, die sind gelb, hast du was von
Amazon Aero mitbekommen, ich weiß nicht, was das ist, was ist das, was ist Amazon Aero,
Aero Mesh Router, was routet der denn, macht das C Raute, Amazon, nein, habe ich nichts
von mitgekriegt, keine Ahnung, was das ist, Brand New 99 Dollar Aero, Aero Router, Home
Mesh Wifi Coverage Dual Band Radio, was für ein Ding, Aero, ok, Aero Secure, Aero Secure
Plus, das klingt schon mal für mich nicht vertrauenserweckend, das ist wahrscheinlich
irgendwas, was Amazon an Zeug entschlüsseln kann oder so, ok, ne, keine Ahnung, aber wozu
braucht man das, was kann das mehr als mein ordentlicher Ubiquiti, wie spricht man das
eigentlich richtig aus, man spricht Ubiquiti ja nicht Ubiquiti aus, Ubiquiti, Moment,
oh Sprache, Ubiquiti, was, Ubiquiti, Ubiquiti, was zum Fall, Ubiquiti, Ubiquiti, Ubiquiti,
ok, Ubiquiti, Ubiquiti, echt so, klingt aus, slow, Ubiquiti, was, das kann ich nicht
aussprechen, das ist zu small, zu small brain habe ich dafür, Ubiquiti, Ubiquiti, Ubiquiti,
ok also, was kann der besser als mein Ubiquiti Access Point, ja außer meine Daten an Amazon
schicken, das ist mir klar, dass der das kann, das kann der besser als mein aktueller Access
Point, ne, also, weiß ich nicht, weiß ich nichts zu, ehrlich gesagt kann ich nichts
zu sagen, ja also wenn ihr irgendwelche Sachen wissen wollt, haut in den Chat rein, ansonsten
eigentlich wollte ich mir jetzt mit euch heute Stellenanzeigen angucken, weil es mal wieder
soweit ist, haben wir schon eine ganze Weile nicht gemacht, ich habe letztens eine Stellenanzeige
gesehen von BKA, ich muss mal gucken ob ich das, ich muss mal gucken ob ich das finde
von BKA, das war lustig, BKA, drops IT, muss ich mal gucken, die Seite sieht irgendwie kacke
aus oder, oder, oder wenn irgendwelche, da wird erstmal gleich der Bundestroianer geploggt
wahrscheinlich, natürlich, das ist Dienstort, das passt wieder wie die Faust aufs Auge,
Fachpersonal für Übersetzung in Sprachen Arabisch und Persisch, Standort Berlin, das
war wieder klar, aber Standort Frankfurt würde ich auch verstehen, ich erlebe ja die kulturelle
Vielfalt jeden Tag am Hauptbahnhof in Frankfurt, der Edge-Law, Twitch Prime, POG, Samus
Clima, Samus Clima, nice, das habe ich letztens, aber nicht Qualifizierungsmaßnahme, sondern
das wahrscheinlich haben sie keinen gefunden, zumindest war das ganz merkwürdig, was die
gesucht haben, das hat mich echt verwirrt, leider finde ich das nicht mehr, vielleicht
hier, Flyer, Cyberkriminalist, war das das, da waren ganz merkwürdige Sachen drin wo
ich mich frage, warum muss ich als Cyberkriminal, also als IT-Mensch bei der Polizei eine Mindestgröße
haben und sowas, muss ich irgendwie eine Mindestgröße haben und so, oh alter 33 Strahl, da bin ich
zu alt für, das ist aber nicht das was ich gesehen habe, Sport-Tester, fuck, doch, doch
du brauchst eine Mindestgröße, jetzt bewerben, ja, Qualifizierungsmaßnahme, ihre Qualifikation,
Größe, ja, also du musst mindestens 61 sein, gut ich meine das sollten die meisten Leute
schaffen aber warum brauche ich als krasser Hexer irgendwie eine Mindestgröße, ach hier
sind es 42 des Lebens, ja ok, 1,59, ja, gute Abschlussnotenabfassung, ich weiß, mein Abschlusszeugnis
von der Ausbildung von vor vielen Jahren, der ist richtig gut, das ist irgendwie 1,2
oder so, weil Berufsschule halt kackeinfach ist, so aber am besten ist was man verdient,
kriegst das hier, kriegst das hier, passt mal auf, da lacht ihr euch kaputt, was man
dafür kriegt, 10, Entgeltgruppe 10, nee, passt so, Moment, muss ich aber auf die Seite gucken,
ja, ein Bezügerechner hier, ja, also, Entgeltgruppe 10, kriegt man da Geld, ok, ich hab keine
Ahnung was das hier für komische Stufen sind, ehrlich gesagt, zumindest ist es fast nichts
gewesen für das was die wollen, was ist denn Stufe 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, was, das ist so eine
typische, das ist echt so eine typische Amtrechenseite hier, ok, 10, was ist Stufe 1, 2, 3, 4, ok,
keine Ahnung, zumindest, jetzt mal ehrlich, das ist, also da musst du noch Steuern drauf
bezahlen, ich mein, hallo, 39k im Jahr, was ist das, dafür hab ich doch keine Mindestgröße
und mach nen Sportkurs für 39k im Jahr, ich mein, ok, ok, man hat wahrscheinlich bessere
Chancen, also bessere Konditionen was Krankenversicherung angeht, wahrscheinlich muss man insgesamt
weniger Steuern bezahlen, weiß ich nicht, aber, guck mal hier, Netto bleibt, also, wer
macht das denn dafür, also, wer, der wirklich qualifiziert wäre, als krasserer Polizeihexer,
also jemand der wirklich Ahnung hat, der macht das nicht, 39k im Jahr, guck mal was man nach
5 Jahren bekommt, sind das hier die Jahre oder was, ja, das, das geht, das geht schon
eher in die Richtung, das würde ich mir schon eher gefallen lassen, ja, das geht, das geht
schon eher in die Richtung, wo ich sag, das ist in, ist Stufe 5, geht das nach Jahren
oder wie, wie funktioniert das, ich weiß nicht, nach Stufe sind nicht Jahre, ich hab
keine Ahnung, zumindest ist es insgesamt nicht viel, das ist, das ist jetzt ungefähr
das, was ich dann, was ich da nicht ganz, was ich mit 4 Tagen in der Woche krieg, nicht
ganz, wohlgemerkt, ja, mit 4 Tagen in der Woche krieg, also, what the fuck, stimmt nicht
ganz, ja, aber trotzdem, ich mein, was die da für Anforderungen haben, wenn man Mindestgröße
außen vor, aber ich mein, ich frag mich dann immer, hat es vielleicht seinen Grund, warum
wir nicht so viel qualifizierte Leute kriegen, vielleicht hat es ja einen Grund, vielleicht
denken sich nämlich richtig krass qualifizierte Leute, dass sie keinen Bock da drauf haben,
also der einzige Grund, also, und dann hab ich übrigens noch einen ähnlichen Job bei
der Bundeswehr gefunden, die haben auch irgendwie so einen krassen, den krassen Soldat-Hacksore
gesucht, du musst aber nicht, du musst aber nicht mit, wirklich als Soldat, sondern wirklich
als Technik-Mensch, sowas ähnliches haben die bei der Bundeswehr auch gesucht und es
wurde auch überhaupt nicht bezahlt, also das einzige, wie ich mir erklären kann, dass
das für das Geld jemand macht, ist eigentlich nur, wenn du so der übertriebene, wie nennt
man es in den USA, Patriot irgendwie bist, also wenn du quasi einfach sagst, sie irgendwie
so für die Gerechtigkeit und keine Ahnung, für Gerechtigkeit und Vaterland und sonst
was, dann nimmst du so einen Job bei der Polizei oder bei der Bundeswehr an für 35k im Jahr,
aber ansonsten würde ich den Leben nicht machen, warum, also da musst du voller Patriot
sein, also das weiß ich nicht, ob es da so viel gut Qualifizierte, was ist denn heute
eine scheiß Mikrofonverlänger, geiler Wackel, Mokras, Mokras Smoke, so jetzt, aber ansonsten
würde ich das nicht machen, sie bringen dich auch durch das Studium, egal was ist, ob das
jetzt so für die Qualität der Leute spricht, wenn du durch das Studium kommst, egal was,
also wenn die dich ordentlich bezahlen, habe ich da überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit, aber
letztendlich arbeitet man ja nicht um Arbeiten, sondern man will was davon haben, zumal ja
auch dazu kommt, dass eigentlich, weil der Polizei jetzt mal außen vor, mögen auch
die ein oder anderen vielleicht fragwürdigen Sachen passieren, aber eigentlich müsstest
du Leute, die quasi sowas bei der Bundeswehr machen, denen müsstest du ja nochmal extra
sowas bezahlen, vielleicht hat der ein oder andere, der Regel sind ja IT Leute, meistens
die meisten, relativ niedfertige Menschen, vielleicht haben die auch ein bisschen was
gegen unsere Politik und gegen das, was die Bundeswehr so macht, dass denen müssen sie
nochmal extra Schmerzensgeld bezahlen, dass sie das machen, die kriegen dicke Zulagen
und Prämie, ja dann ist gut, das ist auch der einzige Grund, warum ich sowas machen
würde, einfach nur wegen der Kohle, ansonsten, weil ich irgendwie so überzeugt davon bin,
bestimmt nicht.
Okay, also wir wollen jetzt mal, guck mal, da gibt es zwar was für mich, bei Apollo
Optik in Schwabach, wo ist denn das, ich weiß nicht, wo Schwabach ist, du zahlst bei der
Bundeswehr keine Sozialversicherung plus keine Krankenversicherung aus Steuern, aber du bekommst
schon ordentliche Versorgung, wenn was ist, also ich meine, wenn du keine Krankenversicherung
bezahlst, kannst du ja keine Krankenversicherung, oder wie ist das, und dann ist das nicht schlecht,
ja, und dann ist das nicht so, Frankfurt schönste Stadt, Frankfurt kriminellste Stadt, ich hab
letztens in Statistik gesehen, Frankfurt gefährlichste Stadt Deutschland von KS, ja, gefährlichste
10 Städte Deutschlands, Frankfurt, die gefährlichsten 10 Städte Deutschlands, Platz 1, doch die
gefährlichste Stadt Deutschlands ist Frankfurt am Main, die Bankenstadt in Hessen erreicht
mit 16.292 Verbrechen pro, ach du Scheiße, das ist ja echt verdammt viel, das ist schon
fast ein Wunder, dass ich da noch nicht überfallen würde oder so, das ist ja übertrieben viel,
das sind 6,25%, äh, nee, quickmaps, so rechnet man das nicht, ne, nee, ich bin nicht, quickmaps,
das sind 16%, lul, ach nee, ich hätte 16 durch 100 rechnen müssen, ne, ja, falsch rum,
falsch rum, big brain, Alter, Leute, big brain, ich hätte 100 durch 16 rechnen müssen,
nicht 16 durch 100, äh, nein, 16 durch 100, nicht 100 durch 16, big brain, 16%, das ist
ganz schön viel, überlegt euch mal, pro 100.000 Personen werden 16% von den Verbrechen begangen
in Frankfurt, Alter, was ist da los, ich sag's euch Leute, gefährlichste Stadt in Deutschland,
ich, im Prinzip, ja, also, sag mal, tief in mir wusste ich das schon immer, dass Frankfurt
kacke ist, also Frankfurt das übelste Drecksloch ist, ja, aber die Statistik haut schon echt
rein, oh, huge host, der Krieger hat mich gehostet mit 279 Zuschauern, Poggers, habt ihr schön
getaucht, keine Ahnung, huge host, Pog, ja, danke für den host, ich bin auch genau eine
halbe Stunde da, ähm, aber Leute, ihr wollt's mir nicht glauben, ne, Sie sehen, das ist
Frankfurt, gefährlichste Stadt, Haftbefehl wusste das schon immer, Frankfurter Ghetto,
zahl die Kollektion bar, fick auf Sponsor, hat er schon immer gesagt, ja, er kennt sich
aus, naja, ähm, aber wenn ich diese Statistik sehe, muss ich sagen, ich wundere mich echt,
dass ich noch nicht überfallen wurde, hab ich euch mal erzählt, dass ich einen, die
hat meinen Chef überfallen, also schon ewig her, schon 10 Jahre her, da muss ich zur Polizei
und wusste, ähm, wusste, dass das Portemonnaie von meinem Chef abholen, vor ewig, da war
ich noch Azubis, ewig her, da haben sie meinen Chef aus, muss wohl wirklich ausgeraubt gewesen
sein, ja, also der hatte nix mehr, der hatte kein Handy mehr danach, der hatte keine, hatte
keinen Portemonnaie mehr, der hatte nix mehr danach, ich glaub, da hatte noch ne Jacke
oder so, ähm, den haben sie halt auch abgerippt am Hauptbahnhof, ja, und die Typen haben sie
halt dann erwischt, und dann musste ich zur Polizei, also hat gesagt, also sie haben angerufen
die Polizei und hat gesagt, hier, sie haben das Portemonnaie und sowas wiedergefunden,
ist kein Geld mehr drin, aber Ausweis und alles, und, ähm, da bin ich zur Polizei,
und da bin ich zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben, in, wie gesagt, schon ne ganze Weile her,
in Kontakt gekommen mit der Frankfurter Polizei, und das war an, äh, Demotivation kaum zu
überbieten, ähm, ich bin da hingegangen, hab am Empfang erstmal so den Typ hinterm,
hinterm, ähm, Panzerglas, ja, hab ich ihm erzählt, hier, na, sowieso, ich soll's von
meinem Chef abholen, äh, mit dem Herr sowieso telefoniert, der hat mir überhaupt nicht
zugehört, er hat erstmal gesagt, ja, haben Sie einen Ausweis dabei, wollen Sie Anzeige
aufgeben, nee, Moment, langsam, ich hab meinen Ausweis dabei, aber, ich will, ich, ich, ich
wurde nicht, ich möchte von meinem Chef das abholen, und der Herr sowieso hat angerufen,
das hat, der hat's nicht gecheckt, der war wirklich, wirklich die Demotivation in Person,
und irgendwann hat er's dann gecheckt, dann ist er an der Tür Brunner geratschfugt, ja,
das war mein erster Kontakt mit der, mit der Frankfurter, mit der Frankfurter Polizei, ansonsten
hab ich einen, echt einen guten Eindruck von der Frankfurter Polizei, ein Chef, nein, ist
er nicht, WTF, warum, sollte ein Schausenhorn sein, hallo, Kieskauer, wie heißt er, Sir
of Jelly, kann man in der IT über 10k verdienen, klar, 7k, also man ist im Monat, nee, das
wird dann schon ein bisschen schwieriger, bei 10k im Jahr kannst du über allem verdienen,
warst du schon nachts am Hauptbahnhof, ja war ich, nachts am Hauptbahnhof, oder besser gesagt,
nachts im Hauptbahnhof, ist eigentlich eines der sichersten Sachen in Deutschland, würde
ich fast sagen, so, so viel Bahnsecurity und Polizei, wie nachts am Hauptbahnhof unterwegs
sein, da passiert nichts, um den Hauptbahnhof sieht es schon ein bisschen anders aus, ach,
redet vom Monatslohn, na also 10k im Monat in der IT sind schon ganz schön viel, also
vielleicht, vielleicht, bevor du Steuern drauf bezahlst, ja, Moselstraße, beste, Mosel, Mosel-Eck
vor allem, Mosel-Eck, Leute, das ist die dreckigste Kneipe, die ich je gesehen hab, also von außen,
von außen, das ist der Wahnsinn, guckt euch an, das ist echt, das ist echt Frankfurter
Ghetto, da laufe ich, da laufe ich jeden Tag vorbei hier, diese Ecke, da war ich nicht,
da war ich noch nicht drin, egal, wurscht, ich bin nur gerade eingefallen, wo es um gefährliche
Städte geht, Frankfurt ist Nummer 1 gefährliche Städte, mehr, mehr gefährliche Stadt gibt's
in Deutschland nicht als Frankfurt, also wenn ihr was wissen wollt, haut's in den Chat,
aber denkt immer dran entwumpelos davor zu schreiben, sonst seh ichs nicht, ja, der eine,
du weißt schon, vollkommen normal in Frankfurt, er schreibt grad in den Chat, wurde an der
Flixbus Haltestelle 2x von Leuten auf Heroin, auf Englisch angelabert, ob ich ne Kippe
hätte, das ist normal in Frankfurt, letzten sind wir Mittagessen gegangen, da hat grad
einer 2 Mädels überfallen, das ist halt Frankfurt, vor allem Kaiserstraße, Taunusstraße, da
hinten in der Ecke, naja, Offenbach, Offenbach ist gar nicht so wild, Offenbach hat einen
ziemlich hohen Ausländeranteil, aber auch nicht überall, Frankfurt ist im Prinzip
schon schlimmer, Offenbach mag auf den ersten Blick schlimmer sein, aber unabstrichlich
ist Frankfurt schlimmer, wird sicher bald abgerippt, ja, genau, würdest du es empfehlen
nach Frankfurt zu ziehen, nö, das ist übelst teuer, es ist scheiße, also es sackt direkt
in Frankfurt zu sein, es ist übelst teuer und anbindungsmäßig, je nachdem wo du bist,
bist du auch nicht schneller auf der Arbeit, wärst du bereit für einen Job woanders hinzuziehen,
wenn die mir so viel bezahlen würden, dass ich das mit meinem Haus hier lohnen würde,
dann schon, aber, äh, wird mir wahrscheinlich keiner so viel bezahlen, wie lange pendelst
du ungefähr, ne, ich lauf ja immer vom Südbahnhof hoch in die Innenstadt, das dauert ne halbe
Stunde, also wenn du das mit dazu nimmst, bin ich ungefähr ne Stunde unterwegs von
Tür zu Tür, aber wenn ich reine Fahrzeit, reine Fahrzeit mit dem Zug würde ich sagen,
so, äh, 20 Minuten und dann noch ne U-Bahn, irgendwie 5 Minuten, bin ne Stunde unterwegs,
weil ich halt morgens so mittags ein Stückchen laufe, da ich mich überhaupt mal am Tag bewege.
Hubkreisen, für die, Emotes machen wir alle, Emotes, übrigens Leute, hab ich euch schon
erzählt, ich hab den, ich hab heut noch nicht einmal den Sellout gestartet, wisst ihr eigentlich,
was ihr tolles mit eurem Amazon Prime Account machen könnt, falls ihr das noch nicht wusstet,
ihr könnt euren Amazon Prime, mit Twitch, äh, mit euren Amazon Prime Account mit Twitch
verbinden und einen Streamer eurer Wahl einmal im Monat mit einem Tier-One-Sub unterstützen,
ihr habt alle Vorteile, die ein normaler Sub hat, der Streamer hat auch alle Vorteile,
die ein normaler Sub, äh, bringt, die einzigen, die kein Geld sehen, ist Twitch und Amazon,
also, da gibt's eigentlich nix lang zu überlegen. Und es verlängert sich nicht automatisch,
ne, kein Skamars-Abo-Flatrate. Endlich mal das Sellout, ne? Kannst du das? Ne, ne, braucht
mir nix. Aber Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel Richtung Hauptbahnhof ist nachts gar nicht so wild.
Ähm, ich glaube, es liegt zum, also, ich will nicht sagen, dass da nix ist, aber je nachdem,
wo das ist, ist es gar nicht so wild, weil, ähm, also Bahnhofsviertel nicht, die Straßen
zum Hauptbahnhof sind manchmal, oder meistens nachts nicht so wild, weil mittlerweile sind
dort, wo früher die ganzen Rotlicht-Geschichten waren, also, ich mein, die halbe Kaiserstraße
ist mittlerweile Friseure, Dönerläden, äh, türkische Gemüseläden und sowas in der Richtung,
und die haben alle Security vor ihren Läden stehen nachts.
Ezio, abonniere Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Pock. Was hältst du davon, dass alle Handys
die Klinke abschaffen, total beknackt. Ich hab jetzt auch so eins, ich hab jetzt ein
iPhone, äh, XR, ist R10. X-Files, zwei Monate aktuell im Fortlauf, äh, was, äh, zwei
Monate aktuell, im ersten fortlaufenden Monat. Big-Brains-Up.
Malat4, Twitch Prime, jetzt geht's aber ab hier. Der IQ vom Chat steigt beachtlich mit jedem
Sub, ne, mal angemerkt. Hast du nach deiner Informatik-Auspielung noch
studiert? Nein. Wie findest du Fields-Support? Du meinst jemand, der vor Ort zu den Leuten
hinfährt und da irgendwelche Dinge repariert? Ich find generell jeglichen Endkunden-Support
letztens. Halbkorn hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Was hältst du von Custom-Roms? Ja, ich, ich würd mir wünschen, dass es für manche Tablets,
die ich habe, ein ordentliches Custom-Rom gibt. Ich mag hier den Spruch, hast du Prime, baller
ihn rein. Das hört sich für mich eher Copper Pride an.
Naja, aber eigentlich wollten wir ein paar Stellenanzeigen angucken. Wir haben jetzt
leider nur eine halbe Stunde Zeit, aber gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal, was es gibt, ja.
DevOps-Engineer bei Nürnberg. Nürnberg ist mir ein bisschen weit weg, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber wir können ja mal kurz gucken, was sie schreiben. Apollo-Optik. Was wollen sie denn
haben? Wisst ihr, was ich an dieser Stellenanzeige
schon mal ziemlich gut finde, ohne dass ich jetzt näher gelesen hab? Dass sie nicht anfangen
mit, wir sind der größte, beste, tollste und Marktführer im Bereich XY. Weil so Stellenanzeigen
gehen mir immer auf den Keks. Wie sich den ersten Abschnitt erstmal komplett selber
loben müssen. Wann kommt das Video zum, über den gerouteten
Staubsauger? Naja, ein Video mit dem Staubsauger an sich mache ich nicht. Ich mache ein Video,
wo ich versuche, Minecraft auf dem Staubsauger laufen zu bringen. Schauen wir mal, ob das
funktioniert. Im Livestream ein frisches Android auf sein Tablet portieren. Wir portieren nicht,
wir können, wir können mal, wenn ihr wollt, können wir im Livestream mal ein Tablet routen
oder ein Tablet flashen, können wir mal machen. Was wir nicht machen werden, ist das Amazon
Fire Tablet flashen, weil man darf nicht vergessen, Twitch ist von Amazon und ich glaube, Amazon
ist nicht so scharf drauf, dass man seine Fire Tablet routet. Vor allem live im Stream.
Wie hast du dich nach deiner Ausbildung weitergebildet bzw. was kannst du empfehlen? Bin ich nach
eineinhalb Jahren fertig und mache schon das Cisco Netzwerk, das ist doch gut. Also, ich
habe ja angefangen quasi bei einem Provider, habe ich euch ja erzählt. Jetzt bin ich da,
wo ich schon eine Weile bin. Von da bin ich ja dann gewechselt, dort, wo ich jetzt bin.
Da bin ich jetzt ja auch schon wieder eine ganze Weile. Also, die beste Weiterbildungsvariante
ist tatsächlich, sich selbst weiterzubilden in einem Bereich, den man, der einem gefällt,
weil nur, wenn man in einem Bereich wirklich Spaß hat oder in einem Bereich hat, der einem
gefällt, nur dann wird man auch richtig gut in dem Bereich. Man kann, deswegen, das finde
ich bei diesen Motivationsvideos auf YouTube immer doof, ne? So nach dem Motto, die, ja,
ich kenne diese Sachen, so nach dem Motto, ich komme mit einem fetten Auto rein gefahren,
so nach dem Motto, mit diesem einfachen Trick, 50 Millionen, bla, easy life, easy lifestyle
am Strand, die tun immer so, so nach dem Motto, alter, mach was, überwinde dich, streng dich
an, kauf mein Zeug, ich hab Visionen, alter. Das halte ich persönlich für totalen Schwachsinn,
irgendwas zu machen, was man kacke findet. Wenn man sich zu irgendwas zwingt, wenn man
sich dazu zwingen muss, was zu machen, wird man da drin nie richtig gut werden. Man wird
nur richtig gut in einem Bereich, der einen eh interessiert und dadurch, dass auch der,
dass einen der Bereich interessiert, wird man auch immer besser in dem jeweiligen Bereich
und umso besser man wird in diesem jeweiligen Bereich, umso höher ist die Chance, dass
du natürlich auch später in diesem Bereich arbeiten kannst, weil du dich eben richtig
gut auskennst. Also next level, richtig big brain, also das beste ist wirklich, in dem
Bereich, der dir Spaß macht und der dir gefällt, einfach, dich komplett immer weiter ins Detail,
die Richtung, wo es dir gefällt, einzuarbeiten. Minecraft auf dem Staubsaal, ja, das mach
ich noch, doch, doch. Was hast du eigentlich von deiner Physi-Ausbildung gelernt, oh ne,
das will ich nicht. Ja, mittlerweile schon Lineage OS auf dem Fire Tablet, das hab ich
gesehen. Ich wollte mein, ich hab ja mir, letztes Jahr Weihnachten hab ich mir Fire HD10s gekauft,
eins hab ich schon ein bisschen entschlackt von Amazon, weil ich weiß nicht, wie weit
das die scharf drauf sind, sowas im Stream erzählt, das nächste werd ich auch Lineage,
Lineage, links da drauf flaschen. Wenn ihr Fragen habt, müsst ihr immer at wo plus schreiben,
mein Teil, sonst seh ichs nicht. Man muss halt 40 plus Jahre arbeiten, ist doof, wenn
man keinen Bock hat, muss man nicht. Wenn man natürlich das Geld zum Fenster rausschmeißt,
wenn man einen ganz guten Job hat, muss man 40 Jahre arbeiten. Es gibt einen YouTube Channel,
wo angeblich die Programmierfragen in einem Vorstellungsgespräch nachgespielt werden.
Interviewing IO heißt der Channel, wie realistisch sind solche Videos? Keine Ahnung, kenn ich nicht.
Wollen wir mal gucken? Wollen wir uns das mal angucken? Kenn das nicht, keine Ahnung.
Wie heißt das? Interview IO? Ah, das ist, das ist auf Englisch, okay. Weiß ich nicht,
was haben die? Was haben die so zu? Python Interview Netflix Engineer, Binary Array Partition.
Sollte es nicht eher Binary Search heißen? Was soll, was soll, was soll denn? Also entweder
bin ich schon mal nicht big brain genug, um überhaupt den Titel zu verstehen. Das könnte
ich schon mal nicht zu Netflix ohne sie meint wirklich Binary Search in einem sortierten
Array. Okay, quasi auch immer, also es ist ja nur Python, das ist ja sonst C plus, oh,
E